we share seven animals no well I saw the
cat yeah we have three cats and four
dogs four dogs yeah yeah so you threw
your dog a Quinceanera right yeah that's
amazing what do you mean hey I don't
have kids
I don't have a daughter to do a party
for him well how old is a a Hispanic
girl when she gets 112.
15 minutes
okay
close enough Bobby I only know foreign
numbers so um but your dog wasn't 15.
yeah there she is that's my dog
so cute she is actually closer to 17. uh
that's my dog other dog Vinnie oh Vinnie
yeah are they all chihuahuas yeah
they're both they're both on their uh
chihuahuas yeah but the quinceanera was
like quinceanera is a big party and a
celebration and a rite of passage yeah
you know your girl becoming a woman and
uh that's that's the way Quinceaneras go
yeah yeah but what I did was my
Quinceanera that I threw for my dog yeah
is the best use of the word epic
yeah because there's that the a 10
second 10 second clip went viral and
they showed this clip all over Mexico
like oh my God I wish I was his dog like
a party this party oh my God look at
that oh my God you could just
that you can see just everything that's
around yeah yeah the balloons and the oh
my God
the humans don't even get that [__]
exactly was he grateful she and you know
what my my pets are everything my babies
yeah that's amazing I felt good people
you know people were [__] on me for
for throwing that party and I didn't
care I'm like you know what it's not
your dog who gives who gives a [__] dude
[__] yeah you love your dog yes
celebrate your dog we had over 400
people at the party whoa I invited 400
people to this thing they all the RSVP I
did the RSVP thing too they all showed
up and then uh I told everybody you guys
can take pictures and video just don't
take pictures or video of me it's not
about me it's about my dog because it
wasn't like a fan event it was like I
know everybody that's there yeah but
then someone recorded that video Yeah
while I was pushing the stroller and
posted it yeah and so next thing I know
I got calls from all these morning radio
shows and and tell you know AB was it uh
Good Morning America everybody wanted to
talk about this and I was actually I was
into it yeah and um
I was mad at first yeah but then it's
like all right it's out might as well
try to control the thing yeah yeah I
posted it on my social media and um yeah
most people were supportive but then of
course it's like you got people that
hate stuff like that I had one guy
that's like you have any idea how many
people you could have fed with that
because the number one question was how
much did you spend because you could
tell that was you know I'm not gonna lie
that was a couple of Escalades right
there yeah
so once word got out they're like you
know how many people you could have fed
yeah I'm like oh my God I don't know
what 400 that's how many invited
yeah yeah yeah and then uh yeah so it
was you know it sucked because you don't
want to hear people talking smack about
you know game one you did nothing wrong
well it's like
it's like nothing right you can't
absolutely you might as well just do
whatever the [__] you want yeah I mean
or try yeah yeah I mean it's so weird
this internet thing is it's like you
know when if because we when we started
comedy before it yeah it's before social
media like the internet I still have my
original AOL account what was your uh
well I still have it so then
oh they're fine hey man what the [__]
are you doing
I'll write it down
hey Gabe so we you know we knew each
other we were young right and then when
did you find out that things shifted for
you well I mean it's just one thing I
think that there was a lot of you know
points yeah in the way where all this
led to this and this led to that and
this so there was a lot of things I mean
you figure I started in